la economía de directo América con
Daniela Blandón es Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola Buenos días Ángela vamos a
comenzar hablando de la solución que
parece entrar en el Horizonte para el
colapso del silicon Valley Bank así
después en la bolsa de Nueva York
despertó esta mañana y todos nosotros
despertamos esta madrugada con este
anuncio del First citizens de que
adquirirá la operación del fallido
silicon Valley Punk la información fue
confirmada directamente por la
corporación Federal de seguros de
depósitos que como sabemos es la misma
que tomó el control de este banco a
principios de este mes y desató también
turbulencia en todos los mercados según
este acuerdo la unidad First citizens
Banks Trust Company con sede en Carolina
del Norte va a asumir los activos de
silicon
110 mil millones de dólares también sus
depósitos por 56 mil millones de dólares
y préstamos por otros 72 mil millones de
dólares esta entidad informó a su vez
que a partir de este lunes y una vez se
cierre completamente este negocio las 17
sucursales anteriores de silicon Valley
Bank van a comenzar a operar bajo una de
sus divisiones pero sin cambio de nombre
y los clientes podrán seguir accediendo
a sus cuentas normalmente
Cómo reaccionan Las bolsas a esta
noticia pues Ángela esta noticia es un
bálsamo para el mercado ya que silicon
Valley Bank fue el banco más grande en
quebrar desde la crisis financiera del
2008 Y eso aumentó las tensiones en todo
el sector bancario a nivel mundial A
partir de ese diez de marzo cuando se
anunciaba que lo estaban tomando en
posición del gobierno esta crisis de
confianza también condujo a la quiebra
del signo German cuyos depósitos y
préstamos serán asumidos por una unidad
del New York Community van corpa el
colapso también contagió a Europa y
obligó al segundo banco más grande de
Suiza al Credit Suiza a aceptar un
rescate por parte de su rival y hubiese
de ahí que entonces toda esta noticia
haya sido pues una muy buena para los
mercados ya que pues las bolsas europeas
por ejemplo reaccionan con gran
entusiasmo sus principales índices
registran importantes ganancias del más
del uno por ciento el día de hoy pero el
mercado mundial desde luego sigue
preocupado por la posibilidad de una
crisis crediticia como Explica el
siguiente analista
para mí el problema bancario es solo el
efecto no la causa del problema nuestro
problema en este mundo financiero es un
sobre endeudamiento dramático y a todos
los estados les gusta que los bancos
tomen estos bonos gubernamentales pero
cuando las tasas de interés aumentan
drásticamente esos títulos valen menos
Entonces los estados finalmente deberían
aprender a endeudarse menos de lo
contrario tendremos un problema
insostenible a largo plazo cambiamos de
tema a otro gran titular y es Israel los
sindicatos están amenazando con irse a
huelga general si no se retira el
proyecto de reforma judicial cada vez
más acorralado así es cada vez más
acorralado porque está iniciativa de
benjamines añajo que le daría El
Ejecutivo el control sobre el
nombramiento de los jueces de la Corte
Suprema y también le permitiría anular
los fallos judiciales sobre la base de
una mayoría parlamentaria simples o
según sus detractores pues ha provocado
protestas masivas durante semanas y
hemos venido informando acá en France 24
pero también ha traído críticas por
parte del establecimiento empresarial la
unión general de trabajadores de Israel
que es el mayor sindicato del país
anunció que si el gobierno no detiene
esta reforma comenzará una huelga
general que se extendería a incontables
sectores de la economía hoy por ejemplo
se suspendieron los despegues desde el
Aeropuerto bengulión de tel aviv
mientras que los principales puertos
marítimos y hospitales y servicios
médicos cesaron operaciones Asimismo la
sucursales de McDonald's también
tuvieron que cerrar sus puertas el
cheque que es la moneda local israelí ha
experimentado grandes oscilaciones en
las últimas semanas pero hoy iba
subiendo casi un 1% media jornada y
también las acciones en el mercado de lo
hacían en un 2%, esto por qué porque
están creciendo las expectativas de que
el proyecto será retirado Y eso pues les
da ánimos A los inversionistas
vamos ahora a Alemania que vive la peor
huelga del país en décadas Así es los
aeropuertos incluidos dos de los más
grandes del país en Múnich y en
Frankfurt así como las estaciones de
autobús y de tren de toda Alemania
estaban paralizados en el lunes lo que
provocó interrupciones para millones de
personas a medida que la economía más
grande de Europa se está tambaleando por
los altos precios no es la única también
sus vecinos lo están haciendo esta
huelga es de 24 horas es convocada por
dos de los sindicatos más grandes del
país y lo que busca es presionar por
aumentos salariales para mitigar los
efectos de la inflación que como sabemos
llegó al 9,3% anual en febrero una de
las más altas de la Unión Europea el
sindicato verdi exige un alza salarial
del 10,5% mientras que evg pide un
aumento del 12% de todas maneras ha
habido reuniones pero todavía no ha
habido un punto de encuentro con el
gobierno como veremos también a
continuación
muchas personas incluidas las que
trabajan en el sector de los servicios
públicos sufren Los Altos precios de la
energía y la alta inflación y es por eso
que nuestra labor es llegar a una buena
conclusión presentamos una buena oferta
ahora espero que los sindicatos se
alejen de sus altas demandas y se reúnan
con nosotros en algún lugar del camino
esperamos una oferta negociable sobre la
mesa pero hasta el día de hoy no tenemos
una
para el cierre al multimillonario Ya
regresa a China si Ángela Este es el
fundador del gigante alibaba fue visto
en una escuela fundada por el mismo por
el mismo en 2017 y de esta manera pone
fin a una estadía en el extranjero de
más de un año que la industria había
visto en ese momento como un reflejo del
mal estado de ánimo de sus negocios
privados también de su floja relación
con Beijing Pues hay quienes dicen que
el nuevo Primer Ministro de ese país se
habría acercado a Jack ma ya que el
regreso del empresario más conocido de
China podría ayudar a calmar las
preocupaciones del sector privado
después de una fuerte represión
regulatoria que ha habido Durante los
últimos dos años pues Daniela nos vemos
más adelante para más noticias
económicas Así es Ángela